I don't think this will work nor am i
totally sure why I'm doing this should
be the opening for every video I've ever
made on the internet ever yes all my
hair acceptance fell out because I went
swimming over the weekend and yes I did
run for headfirst into a tree the only
tree in the backyard and yes I was sober
don't worry you're better than me that's
why I'm fun to watch
I gotta do something good no no you know
you're look it's different now north of
July just happened the summer is here
it's barbecue central I assume unless
you don't like that and two of the most
major summer barbecue foods are hotdogs
and hamburgers but because I have free
time I thought what if you made
hamburgers out of hotdogs pour hot
burgers ham dogs and dogs isn't that M
dog is also you know probably the only
sporting team our group for handoffs so
that's what we're going to do today I
don't have a grill but I have an indoor
grill ever got some ground chicken
breasts to make actual chicken am
burgers but I'm going to stuff some of
them with these wieners the entire
aesthetic of my food and cooking has
just been how can I put a wiener in that
deal with it okay let's just do this the
first one to do is brined up our wiener
wipes me up somebody I'm going to use
this we're gonna grind under Wien and
then we're going to see if they can
stick together rough chop some wings and
add them to our chopping things wife me
up and Mark did you hear that not only
was that two wings flapping together it
was also sound of this video being flat
okay rough chop at sexual something's
very cathartic about this little Becca
right above it was an amazing chef here
we go
whoa this is working
Wow it's working whoa the odor is
specific look at that look again I don't
know why anyone would need to try and do
this in their lives hot those are pretty
good as is but if you like staving off
your own boredom maybe try this so their
wieners in the bowl if they'd grind this
very well I was worried that it wouldn't
be moist enough to bind together but
never meets my hot dog moist so now I'm
going to add some breadcrumbs and an egg
because that's sometimes what goes in
hamburgers right I can crack it with one
hand that is actually a good job I'm
know am i turning a corner becoming
capable wow this is working well and I
feel uncomfortable with that
oh is it break up now we mix that up
because mmm Oh salt and pepper
I guess because we're doing well now get
our grill pan out and start heating that
up now for Mia's wieners into patties Oh
touching it does not feel nice that's
they were never going to say about your
ween look at that disgusting and almost
identically my skin colour which is just
add to how disgusting this is why are we
doing this please subscribe
that was for auto once we got three
paddy let's put some oil on the grill
let's put our Weiner patties on the
grill and one on I'll bring you guys
over you can see about going up your
shirt don't look at anything happening
in it hey guys so welcome to this part
of the kitchen whoa that sounds like
cooking is happening the good thing
about hot dogs is because it's not real
meat I think it doesn't matter if it
cooks completely through don't quote me
on that you need hot dogs wrong here all
dogs uh-huh now we cook them for an
indefinite and undetermined amount of
time you don't look at how 30 everything
is over there stop judging me oh man
love nature like what a young girl tries
to do to her closeted boyfriend let's
flip on whoa that looks burnt that's
[ __ ] so we burned them big time they
look more like am burgers now put you
back in your other spot I don't want you
to get this close to the failures that
are currently happening
don't know what they're cooked in the
middle but that's the clown gamble in
cooking you wonder if you're going to
make yourself sick I smell specific also
have some cheese to try one with cheese
on it I have a lack of sensitivity so I
got nut cheese
I have everything sound like a slipknot
scrotum in my mouth I'll do two with
cheese whoa look at that now it has
cheese on it and I got ketchup a mustard
let's do that because why not
oh I overshot wow that's beautiful you
know some of you don't like mixing
things but it was it hopper hot burger
hand dogs whoa Wow look how convincing
these look look at that they look like
real hamburgers kind of there you go we
got our hand dog again don't know why
this would even be something interesting
for you to try at home but if you do
please tweet photos at me or tag me on
instagram at great public across all
social media platform I feel like I've
underwhelmed myself
let's try one Cheers I don't know if
it's wrong in the middle but I'm
swallowing it the echoes of essa she
says ring proudly through the lounge not
bad you guys pretty okay I feel so
mediocre about everything that's
happening right now Wow okay I should
leave before something spectacular or
miserable happens thank you guys so much
for watching if you like this video give
it a thumbs up and click subscribe
because I make videos Monday Wednesday
and Friday
sometimes Elizabeth oliday and um unless
it's just oh well you can't get my Grey
Poupon Oh [ __ ] please don't leave
please stay